[Music]
seven-year-old blind piano prodigy aims
at Venice making quite an impression on
American Idols Queen tribute night I'll
be starting over 70 all the Oreos I am a
viral sensation little a that may have
struck out but Katy hopes contestant
Lane party has better luck
after dewetting with Lacey key boos I've
never seen you smile that large Lane I'd
be wondering if something else
no okay listen that's what you want
people to feel and I felt it Petey was
with the pair backstage where they set
the record straight and broke our hearts
just a little bit per usual we got our
weekly dosage of quirky Katy
here she is hiding under the judges
table after one of her jokes fell a bit
flat yeah I mean all right Katy there
the competition is getting even more
intense as the top eight got whittled
down to the top six two contestants got
the boot Walker Burrows and ELISA ragu
it's been stinky but you know it happens
you know at first I was like ah you know
that sucks that doesn't change how
grateful I am for this opportunity the
judges do have one saved that they can
use before the season is over but they
told et back steamed why they chose to
not use it we've collectively felt like
America got it right again there is a
chance if American gets it right we they
may do them that we may not have to pull
that car you'll have to tune in and
watch where I got I've been saying for
way too long like I am okay if I get
because I'm I just feel so proud we meet
top ten I feel like it's whatever place
you fall in it
who does what with their dream after
that and I'm not stopping I mean at this
point this is what I want to do so I
don't really think I'm I'm getting out
anytime soon I just
I would never drift off into another
career like this is it you know
[Music]